bonjour pierre picca merci d'avoir
accepté son invitation ce matin sur rtl
france alors on le voit un retour de
confinement en chine alors que
finalement il n'y a pas grand nombre de
cas qui ont été détectés en tout cas la
chine qui poursuit sa politique de zéro
qu'ovide des mesures qui sont trop durs
à votre avis où c'est finalement là la
bonne stratégie à mettre en place à la
halle approche des géo oui alors tout à
fait approche des jeux olympiques et si
la stratégie de la chine depuis le début
parce que la chine n'est pas épargnée
malgré une politique qui vise à
éradiquer le coc vide donc 7 cette
action du gouvernement chinois vivent
surtout bien évidemment les jeux
olympiques de pékin qui vont avoir lieu
maintenant en début d'année et pour cela
est bien la plus grande une des plus
grandes villes chinoises une ancienne
capitale impériale sial va donc être je
dirais entièrement purifier ou nettoyer
pour éviter une propagation urbaine qui
est logique comme dans nos grandes
villes cependant en chine et d'après les
dernières nouvelles que j'ai eues hier
au téléphone la plupart des régions
chinoises sont relativement épargnés et
politique et que les régions de deux
campagnes du sud de l'est ou du nord du
pays est bien actuellement le virus n'a
pas refait surface il s'agit
essentiellement d'aidé grandes
métropoles donc cian qui est une
magnifique ville de rotary
ça fait maintenant pratiquement deux ans
un peu plus de deux ans que que le
corona virus
est apparu justement en chine comment
vivent
et
les chinois set face à cette situation
justement ceux qui sont confinés ce
qu'il accepte plutôt bien ils
comprennent les mesures du gouvernement
alors bien évidemment mais eux si vous
voulez en dehors de la première période
que les chinois ont vécu en premier il
donc c'était pour eux comme pour nous
tous une grande émotion je dirais qu'on
ne prend on ne parle pratiquement plus
du coc vide un petit peu comme chez nous
dans la vie quotidienne sauf
effectivement quand un événement comme
cela arrive et qui concerne une région
ou en tout cas une grande métropole
comme cian donc comment le vivent les
chinois et bien je pense qu'ils sont
tournés vers l'avenir et aujourd'hui on
veut espérer effectivement que comme une
pandémie dure généralement deux à trois
années que 2022 sera un nouveau départ
pour tout le monde y compris pour les
chinois donc aujourd'hui les chinois
globalement seul j'irais se propage vers
2002 vers 2022 pardon est aujourd'hui
sans plus a même plutôt que de faire des
projets d'après qu'ovide que de rester
dans locaux vides et pour la population
de dexia que je connais bien eh bien je
crois que les habitants vont partager je
dirais cet effort collectif pour essayer
de 2 comment dire de d'embellir les jeux
olympiques et puis de mettre fin au co
vide pour cette nouvelle année
concernant les jeux olympiques justement
le comité a fait savoir qu'il crée les
voilà dès l'apparition de deux clusters
les athlètes aussi ronron des règles
bien strictes à suivre durant cette
quinzaine olympique
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
justement à ce que la chine met en place
une sorte de bulle spéciale pour les
pour les athlètes durant ces géo écouter
ce serait logique que la chine fasse un
effort encore supplémentaires comme nous
l'aurions fait d'ailleurs pour toute
manifestation internationale qui qui qui
qui ont lieu d'ailleurs en france oui il
faut effectivement des mesures
exceptionnelles quoique la chine est
globalement n'est pas un pays
globalement un risque mais la chine a
pris 7 cette mesure de renforcer avec le
comité international olympique toutes
les mesures d'hygiène également pour
offrir la meilleure garantie aux
sportifs et plus aux visiteurs qui
auront la chance de voir ces jeux
olympiques merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir répondu à nos questions pierre
picard ce matin je rappelle que vous
êtes géopolitologue spécialiste de la
chine et auteur du livre à la
renaissance de la route de la soie
l'incroyable défi chinois du 21ème
siècle aux éditions favre